Frau Kimmich vielleicht die Frage direkt
an Sie also sie haben das so erlebt Sie
sie öffnen diese App sie öffnen tiktok
und es erscheinen diese drei Bilder
dieser Mädchen ungepixelt und verfremdet
obwohl sie gar nicht danach gesucht
haben also wir haben tatsächlich letzte
Woche recherchiert und bei einer
Kollegin Balis tatsächlich so dass das
als erstes Bild gekommen ist man hat ja
zu Beginn diese for you Page und es
kommen dann Bilder die tatsächlich zu
dem Suchverlauf passen natürlich
recherchieren wir in unserem Team als
klicksafe auch in solchen Medien und
dann passt es ähm ich hatte allerdings
mit tiktok Kontakt und das ist nicht
mehr so die haben das tatsächlich
rausgenommen die sagen sie sind ihr eng
mit unseren Strafverfolgungsbehörden in
Kontakt und sie haben sehr schnell
reagiert ähm das ist tatsächlich auch so
allerdings wenn man in die Tiefe sucht
findet man immer noch was und ähm sie
haben mir auch glaubhaft versichert dass
sie im Moment das versuchen so schnell
es geht wieder rauszunehmen aber es
kursiert bei Twitter es passiert bei
Instagram und es wird wieder
reingesprüht und das ist das Problem das
heißt sie sind auch angewiesen auf das
Melden der Nutzer okay welche Rolle
soziale Medien möglicherweise spielen
bei dieser zunehmenden
Gewaltbereitschaft darüber wollen wir
gleich sprechen also nicht aber
vielleicht die Frage an Sebastian vieler
wenn sie sowas hören Freudenberg zwei
Mädchen 12 13 Jahre alt bringen ein
anderes Mädchen um 12 Jahre alt was löst
das bei Ihnen aus
Fassungslosigkeit zunächst einmal
so geht es wahrscheinlich allen allen
die auch Kinder haben einfach das nicht
mehr in diesem Alter aber trotzdem
versucht man sich ja zu vergegenwärtigen
in welcher Situation ist das Opfer
gewesen wie geht's den Eltern jetzt
natürlich und dann kommt erstmal
wirklich lange nichts das muss man
tatsächlich sagen weil es ja sofort klar
ist dass es jetzt
nicht so einfache Antworten gibt da
drauf also es eignet sich nicht für
irgendeine politische Überschrift oder
schnellschussforderung oder so etwas
anders als bei anderen Themen wo man
eigentlich Ideen hat was jetzt
eigentlich zu tun ist ist das hier nicht
so das unter anderem auch deswegen so
weil so schlimm sich das vielleicht auch
anhört auch bei den Täterinnen also die
ja auch noch Kinder sind natürlich auch
noch einen Schutzglocke drüber gelegt
wird das heißt anders als bei
Erwachsenen Tätern erfahren wir in der
Presse jetzt auch nicht die Details und
können uns deswegen auch nicht darüber
unterhalten was jetzt möglicherweise in
Wirkung zusammen mal gewesen sein könnte
sie sprechen da gerade ein ganz heiklen
Punkt an Frau Winter ich habe das Zitat
nicht mehr ganz genau im Kopf aber einer
der Ermittler sagte was für Kinder ein
Motiv ist muss für Erwachsene nicht
unbedingt zu verstehen sein was meint er
damit ja ich kenne es jetzt eher so aus
dem Zusammenhang Selbstgefährdung also
jetzt nicht Fremdgefährdung weil das ist
eben wirklich ein seltenes Ereignis mit
dem wir nicht so häufig zu tun haben
also Eigengefährdung heißt dass ich ein
Kind oder Jugendlicher versucht das
Leben zu nehmen und da kenne ich das
schon dass das eben ganz wichtige
Anlässe sind zum Beispiel eine hohe
Handyrechnung oder etwas
führen kann dass jemand sagt ich sehe
keine Ausweg mehr dass mir das Leben
sind ein jugendlich im Endeffekt
versuchen sie sich das Leben zu nehmen
er sitzt ein Beispiel ja und ähm das
wäre ja für uns als Erwachsener gar kein
Grund das kann man ja überhaupt nicht
mit einem Leben aufwiegen und insofern
könnte natürlich da auch sowas aber wir
wissen viel zu wenig darüber und das
einer der Gründe warum diese Forderung
die ja sofort ich habe es vorher gesagt
als ich diesen schlimmen Fall las habe
ich gesagt das werden die ersten kommen
und werden sagen wir müssen die
strafmöglichkeit jetzt senken ja es gibt
ja andere Länder auf der Erde ich glaube
in den Vereinigten Staaten gibt es
Bundesstaaten wo sechsjährige
eingesperrt werden und es hat nicht
lange gedauert und die Forderung war
tatsächlich da obwohl wir eigentlich
nichts darüber wissen und obwohl die
Zusammenhänge eben bei Kindern völlig
andere sind das bei erwachsen
in der Schweiz glaube ich beginnt die
Strafmündigkeit ab zehn ins Gefängnis
geht man glaube ich aber erst ab 15
warum warum diese Grenze die gibt es in
Deutschland glaube ich schon sehr sehr
lange ne für 14 haben glaube ich die
Nazis mal für einen kurzen Zeitraum auf
12 heruntergesetzt und dann wieder hoch
auf 14 warum ist die so wichtig
naja sie ist erstmal aus der Sicht der
Strafverfolger wichtig weil dann ein
Instrumentarium greift das heißt sie
überhaupt ist die Staatsanwaltschaft es
zuständig die Polizei ist erst zuständig
weil dann der Strafgesetzbuch überhaupt
erst zu dem Gesetz wird das dann
Anwendung findet dann sind wir noch
lange nicht mehr wachsenden Strafrecht
das heißt die Idee beim Jugendstrafrecht
also von 14 bis 18 im Regelfall ist die
dass man diesen Erziehungsgedanken im
Vordergrund hat das heißt so ein
Jugendstrafverfahren findet natürlich
anderen Maßstäben statt die Frage ist
nur wenn wir sozusagen verschieben
dieser Grenze sprechen was bedeutet das
dann also
umgekehrt heißt das doch damit verstehe
diese zwei Mädchen begehen diese
fürchterliche tat
und es hat natürlich viel für sie
persönlich emotional für die Eltern für
die Familie ein Leben lang Konsequenzen
ist überhaupt keine Frage für die
Familie des Opfers sowieso aber
strafrechtlich bedeutet das für Sie sie
gehen nach Hause und das passiert nichts
nein es passiert nichts es ist die Frage
ist nicht das passiert nichts das ist
kein Strafrecht folgt also Strafrecht da
gibt es lange wissenschaftliche
Überlegungen dazu was eigentlich der
Zweck des Strafrecht ist und das habe
ich gerade schon angedeutet dass bei
Erwachsenen normal völlig anders na da
kommt noch so eine Mini kleine Sühne
Komponente dazu oder vereinfacht würde
man sagen Rache die Gesellschaft will
noch mal Sühne sehen das ist das ist
streitig aber es ist Teil dieser
Theorien die da eine Rolle spielen aber
schon bei Jugendlichen aber nicht mehr
sondern da geht es um eine
erziehungsgedank es geht darum
tatsächlich vereinfacht gesprochen
Jugendliche die der den Quent geworden
sind die Verfehlungen nach dem
Strafgesetzbuch begangen haben wieder
auf den rechten Weg zurückzuführen darum
geht's und darum geht's letztlich auch
bei Kindern deswegen lautet die Frage
tatsächlich welches in die kommentarium
hat eigentlich der Staat zur Verfügung
um damit umzugehen um also diese
Delinquenz wieder zu beenden und dazu
gibt es einen ganzen Haufen von
wissenschaftlichen Untersuchungen die
einfache Wahrheit lautet fast jeder wird
strafbar also hier im Raum ist eine hohe
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass bei männlichen
Jugendlichen sowieso alle mal irgendwann
strafbar irgendeiner Cloud mal okay
jeder der ubiquitär sagt mal also das
heißt Kriminalität im Jugendalter ist
eigentlich an der Tagesordnung jeder im
Laufe des Lebens macht das und in der
überwiegenden Zahl hören alle aber auch
von alleine wieder auf damit weil sie
dann irgendwann einen Reifegrad erreicht
haben so und deswegen bei diesen
heftigen Fällen das ist ein ganz kleiner
Anteil von Kindern und Jugendlichen die
irgendwann gewalttätig werden man
spricht eine Literatur so fünf bis
sieben Prozent sind für etwa zwei
Drittel dieser ganzen Taten
verantwortlich also die auch wirklich
häufiger was man 7% für zwei Drittel
riesengroß sehr schiebt sich mal so ein
bisschen für
alle für einen großen Anteil der
Normalfall in der Gesellschaft ist dass
man irgendwann mal irgendwo über die
Stränge schlägt und auch Strafgesetze
reist aber in der aller Regel über ist
auch gar nicht erwischt wird sondern nur
geringer Teil wird erwischt und das hört
aber von alleine man könnte flapsig
sagen das wächst sich wieder raus so die
Fälle das sind sicherlich keine Fälle
über die von denen die wir mit denen wir
die Sendung jetzt begonnen haben sondern
was man mit solche Sicherheit sagen kann
ich wäre überrascht wenn sie mir wieder
sprechen wenn das die erste Tat gewesen
wäre das kann ich nahezu ausschließen
also das heißt dieses diese
Gewalttätigkeit die dazugekommen ist
kann nach meiner Überzeugung nicht die
erste gewesen sein sondern da muss ein
Vorgeschichte gewesen sein also das
würde ich mal als gesichert voraussetzen
was wir nur nicht wissen ist welche und
dazu gibt es auch eine ganze Bandbreite
und Fülle von theoretischen
Möglichkeiten die dazu gehört haben
könnten das schon im Kindesalter solche
schlimmen Dinge getan werden
umgekehrt die Frage in die Runde gibt es
Untersuchungen darüber noch mal
Altersgrenze mit 14 ist glaube ich sie
sagten gerade da gibt es diesen Sühne
Gedanken für so eine Gesellschaft ich
glaube ja auch dass es für die würde man
sagen für eine Gesellschaft für die
psychische Hygiene auch einer
Gesellschaft durchaus wichtig ist dass
Menschen nicht schlimme Dinge tun
bestraft werden das brauchen wir das
sonst mit allem anderen können wir
glaube ich schlecht umgehen gibt es
Untersuchungen darüber was mit Kindern
passiert sie werden gerade die USA in
England glaube ich gab es auch Fälle wo
sehr junge Kinder eingebuchtet worden
sind eingesperrt worden sind was
passiert mit denen die entwickeln die
sich wie geht so eine Karriere so eine
Geschichte weiter kennen nicht jede
untersuchen habe aber im vorwegen
natürlich mit Kriminologen dann
Kriminologen viel telefoniert und der
Befund ist dass wenn wir uns jetzt
fragen was passiert anschließend mit
denen kommen die dann geläutert wieder
aus so einem Gefängnis heraus lautet die
Wahrheit nein im Gegenteil das Gegenteil
ist der Fall also das verfestigt er
kriminelle Karriere als dass es zu einer
Lösung beiträgt
vielleicht kann ich da was dazu
beitragen welche Erfahrungen haben sie
beide da gemacht also wir sprechen hier
ja von retrospektiven Sanktionen und die
sanktionsforschung sagt eigentlich eine
Retrospektive Sanktion wird nie sehen
seltenen Fällen wirklich beim Probanden
des Verhalten ändern es ist mir eine
Sanktion als normver deutlichende
Wirkung für die Gruppe das heißt leute
passt auf wenn ihr sowas macht wie diese
Person dann landet ihr genauso
irgendwann auch ganz genau
und was wir aber brauchen
tatsächlich für unsere Jugendlichen sind
eher prospektive Sanktionen wo sie mit
Tat Folgen konfrontiert werden um dann
aber auch die Möglichkeit zu bekommen
danach eine Wiedergutmachung ihrer Tat
zu ermöglichen das heißt auch daraus
lernen und das eine
Verhaltensveränderung entstehen kann es
ist ein anderes Denken aus der Pädagogik
heraus
Frau Winter ist es trotzdem wieder
gerade sagte das war klar dass dann
sozusagen sofort die meinetwegen auch
populistische Forderung kommt jetzt das
alte herunter ist es dennoch wieso soll
man sagen verwerflich oder nicht
nachvollziehbar dass seine Gesellschaft
sich genau diese Frage stellt also
dieses Gefühl dass jetzt viele Leute
haben der wird ein kleines Mädchen
umgebracht von 12 Jahren und die beiden
Täterinnen hat das strafrechtlich so gut
wie keine Konsequenzen ähnlich auch in
vielen anderen Fällen auch was passiert
mit denen
ja also die Diskussion kann ich
verstehen aber wie gesagt ich wäre auch
eher zurückhaltend weil es eben
Einzelfälle sind was passiert mit denen
also ich würde mir wünschen und ich gehe
davon aus dass es psychologisch
psychiatrisches Gutachten gibt um die
Situation zu klären also was ging da
voraus liegen psychische Auffälligkeiten
vor und dann eben eine entsprechende
Maßnahmen zu empfehlen Unterbringungen
das geht ja bis hin zur geschlossenen
Unterbringung heilpädagogischer
Unterbringung psychologische Betreuung
Psychotherapie vielleicht auch
medikamentöse Behandlung je nachdem was
das Gutachten auch ergibt das ist ja
auch das ist passiert auch etwas nur
nicht im Rahmen des Strafrechtes sondern
im Rahmen von familiengerichtlichen
Gutachten die klären was der eben was
der beste Schritt also der beste Weg ist
damit sie damit sich sowas nicht noch
mal wiederholt das ist ja das Ziel
dieser Tage an der Aussage von Erich
Recklinghausen gelesen kennen Sie mit
Sicherheit Landesvorsitzender der
Polizei Gewerkschaft in NRW der sagt
heute sind sind viele zwölfjährige wie
16-Jährige was bedeutet wir müssen die
Gesetze entsprechend anpassen was sagt
die jugendpsychiaterin dazu also ich
erlebe das nicht so körperlich ja sind
sie manchmal reifer früher reifer aber
kognitiv finde ich kann ich das so nicht
bestätigen wir sprechen auch von der
verlängerten Adoleszenz ganz
grundsätzlich und man muss ja sagen
gerade durch die Social Media sind die
auch sehr viel mehr ausgesetzt also sehr
viel ungeschützt da weil sie sich mit
ganz ganz vielen Dingen beschäftigen und
auseinandersetzen müssen was ja früher
gar nicht so in dem Maße gegeben war er
sagt weiter das fand ich interessanten
Gedanken für schwerste Straftaten wie
Mord Totschlag Sexualstraftaten muss bei
Tätern unter 14 ein Gutachten erstellt
und die Frage geklärt werden ob dieses
Kind schuldfähig ist also er wird
sozusagen das auf der Basis eines
Gutachtens machen und sagt dieser starre
Rahmen dieser starre Altersbegrenzung
darf in Zukunft keine Rolle mehr spielen
wer das wer das in gangbarer Weg also
das Gutachten was ich jetzt so mir
gewünscht hätte würde jetzt schon eher
darum gehen wie es die Motivlage wie war
die Situation gibt es Diagnosen die
vorliegen und müssen die Behandlung
werden und was ist der weitere Weg nicht
Schuldfähigkeit weil wir vom Gesetzgeber
davon ausgehen dass eben die einzigen
Fähigkeit und die Handlungsfähigkeit
nicht gegeben ist unter 14 und er wird
ja ab von 14 bis 18 dann geprüft ob die
volle verantwortungsfähigkeit da ist
wann beginnt das eigentlich Frau Winter
ab wann können wir als Menschen
sozusagen verstehen ermessen was töten
bedeutet
wann können wir verstehen sozusagen was
die Verantwortung die Konsequenz von dem
ist was wir tun ab wann greift das wann
begreifen wir das als Menschen das erste
Mal naja das ist halt alles ich denke
einfachere Situationen kann das schon
auch mit 12 durchaus möglich sein was
ist recht was ist Unrecht
Alltagssituation aber komplexere
Situationen da können die das dann nicht
übersetzen und diese zum Beispiel die
Endgültigkeit des Todes ist ja auch in
dem Alter 10 bis 14 je nachdem also dass
sie überhaupt verstehen dass es wirklich
endgültig ist wenn jemand nicht mehr
lebt das sind alles Prozesse die in
diesen in diesem Zeitraum stattfinden
und man muss sich das wirklich so
vorstellen hatten unheimlichen
Entwicklungsschub also das ist ja in der
frühen Kindheit so zwischen 0 und 5 und
das ist eben dann noch mal zu Beginn der
Pubertät wir sagen immer das Gehirn wird
umgebaut ne da ist Baustelle sozusagen
und entsprechend ist ganz ganz viel
Entwicklung die sich da vollzieht und
deshalb ist das nicht alles
schon so geordnet wie das jetzt bei
Erwachsenen der Fall ist ich finde man
muss diese Diskussion auch so ein
bisschen einordnen nach meiner
Wahrnehmung ist es so das haben sie
gerade selber so ein bisschen auch
angedeutet dass diese Forderung jetzt so
eine gesellschaftliche Hilflosigkeit
versuchen zu verbalisieren und zu
transportieren und das lässt sich dann
leicht übersetzen so und dann finden wir
eine Lösung und dann wissen wir wie wir
zukünftig mit solchen Fällen umgehen
meine meine
einfach zu sortieren woher kommt jetzt
auf der einen Seite die Forderung die
Strafen Mündigkeit jetzt abzusenken dann
haben wir ja ein anderes reaktionsreport
war und mit solchen Dingen umzugehen das
wirkt aber die große Gefahr dass wir die
viel schwierigere Frage wie wird
tatsächlich jetzt mit nach allem was wir
wissen steigenden Problemlagen also
steigenden Zahlen bei Kinder der links
bei jugendlicher Gewalt gemettet das war
in den letzten Jahren anders wir kommen
aus einer sinkenden Zahl heraus
die schwierige Frage ist was machen wir
denn jetzt eigentlich um das etwas mehr
zu verhindern ja wir haben Konzepte im
Bereich der Jugendlichen Häuser des
jugendrechtes ist auch nicht alles so es
gibt nicht so viele Untersuchungen dazu
die hinterher nahe legen was dann gut
irgendwie hilft aber es gibt durchaus
ein Haufen von Untersuchungen die uns
nahe legen was wir denn besser noch tun
könnten und das ist tatsächlich sind so
Reaktionsschemata wo man versucht eben
doch noch mehr Institutionen und
zivilgesellschaftlich ich sage jetzt mal
Einrichtung bis hin zu Nachbarschaften
da gibt es aus dem großbritannischen
Raum Ideen dafür
zusammenzubringen um tatsächlich in den
Blick zu nehmen was ist denn eigentlich
die ganze Bandbreite von Dingen die
irgendwie dazu kommen können um zu einer
Delinquenz zu führen am Ende und das
kann alles mögliche sein sie finden eine
ganze Liste von Indikatoren also es kann
sein natürlich klassisch das im
Elternhaus was passiert das also Regeln
nicht wirklich nachvollziehbar
übermittelt werden es kann sein dass
beide das Armut eine Rolle spielt
soziale Dinge nicht geordnete
nachbarschaftsgefüge und jetzt könnt ihr
Aufzählung noch ganz ganz lange
weitermachen und das bedeutet bei der
Lösung andersherum dass all diese Dinge
natürlich adressiert werden müssen wenn
ich feststelle ich habe es hier mit
einem Kind oder einem Jugendlichen zu
tun der tatsächlich jetzt mehr als
zweimal schon über die Stränge
geschlagen ist um dann nicht zu warten
bis es noch schlimmer wird und
ehrlicherweise haben wir nicht wirklich
solche Netzwerkstrukturen überall
ausgebildet das hört sich jetzt ein
bisschen kompliziert an aber ich glaube
damit müssen wir uns auseinandersetzen
wir müssen
institutionalisiert solche Strategien
etablieren und müssen sagen okay wir
wissen jetzt welche Möglichkeiten wir
haben und welche Institutionen wir wie
zusammenbringen um im individuellen Fall
für das Kind tatsächlich das Richtige zu
tun es gibt Freudenberg es gibt diesen
sehr traurigen Fall Luise es gibt jetzt
Heide es gibt der den anderen Fall über
den ich von gesprochen habe es gibt den
Bürgermeister von Heidi der sagt wir
haben da ein Problem mit steigender
Jugend und
Kinderkriminalität und wir kriegen es
nicht mehr in den Griff das klingt
ehrlich gesagt wie ein Hilferuf und er
sagt halt ungefähr einem Jahr haben wir
das wir haben jetzt Herbert Roll gehört
den Innenminister von NRW der sagt in
unserer Statistik lässt sich ablesen wir
haben da ein Thema Hendrik wüst der
Ministerpräsident von NRW sagt das auch
und ehrlich gesagt war das genau der
Moment in dem wir auch hier als
Redaktion hellhörig geworden sind und
sagten lass uns bitte mal über dieses
Phänomen sprechen und ich bin völlig bei
Ihnen wenn man nach Amerika guckt dieses
privatwirtschaftlich organisierte
Gefängnissystem also wo sozusagen
Unternehmen genau wo man Geld damit
verdient Leute im Knast zu stecken das
ist grauenvoll und es führt ja auch wie
wir alle immer wieder sehen mitnichten
zu weniger Gewalt aber diese
hilflosigkeiten die spüren wir alle und
die Frage was tun wie wie geht man damit
um und vor allem die Frage woher kommt
das Frau Winter haben Sie eine Idee eine
Ahnung davon warum das plötzlich so
virulent wird mein Gefühl war seit
langer Zeit immer so fertig wie diese
Jugend die wir gerade haben war schon
lange keine mehr also wenn wir mal
reingefühl wir haben uns früher deutlich
mehr geprügelt die sind heute alle ganz
ganz ganz friedfertig unterwegs aber
offensichtlich haben wir irgendeiner
Stelle etwas verpasst naja ich finde
jetzt so die aktuelle Situation es sind
ja jetzt diese 12 13-jährigen und wir
haben ja Corona gehabt ich meine wir
vergessen es jetzt schon ab und zu mal
wieder weil wir nicht mehr so viel die
Masken tragen aber es ist ja drei Jahre
jetzt einfach eine eingeschränktes Leben
gewesen und diese 12 13-jährigen die
sind ja quasi zu Beginn ihre Pubertät
damit konfrontiert worden mit
Schulschließungen mit dass sie eben ihre
Freundinnen nicht mehr sehen konnten
dass sie quasi ihre sozialen Kompetenzen
nicht ausbilden konnten dass sie mehr in
Social Media sich bewegt haben und so
weiter und also diese erste
Schulschließung war ja schon ganz
furchtbar es gab aber noch eine zweite
Schulschließung und also ich glaube
schon wir haben das ja immer gesagt
jetzt aus dem Psycho Bereich dass das
auf jeden Fall folgen hat und wir haben
ja auch wirklich
das Problem also wir kriegen ja niemand
mehr unter weder in der Psychiatrie noch
in der Psychotherapie das erleben wir so
genau es ist ein hoher Andrang die
Krankheit kommen die Kinder die
Jugendlichen was haben die für Themen
also was ja sehr angestiegen ist ist
eben Depression Angst aber auch
Essstörungen also das würde ich jetzt
mal so ganz grob sagen ne also aber auch
Adipositas ne Social Media sie haben
sich weniger bewegt also da gibt's eine
ganze Bandbreite haben die Krankenkassen
ja wunderbar herausgearbeitet und ich
glaube dass diese zwei drei Jahre Corona
eben gerade zu Beginn der Pubertät wo
man eigentlich die vier Group ähm quasi
also die Peer Group Erfahrungen macht
und diese sozialen Kompetenzen
entwickelt und all diese Dinge
voranschreiten müssen das kann man auch
nicht so unbedingt dann nachholen und
jetzt hier eben auch sehr viele Kinder
sehr gefordert sind dadurch dass sie
wieder in die Schule gehen da haben wir
auch ganz viele Aussteiger die gar nicht
mehr reinkommen in der Schulsystem es
gibt Lernschwierigkeiten das nicht genau
also die sind so lange draußen gewesen
ne das ist immer eine große Gefahr wenn
jemand sehr lange nicht in die Schule
geht aus welchem Grund auch immer dass
er dann die mit der Integration Probleme
hat also ich glaube auf jeden Fall das
Corona schon auch dazu beiträgt dass es
da jetzt eine Steigerung
gewaltsteigerung gibt weil da einfach
ein Lernprozess nicht stattgefunden hat
und das ist jetzt gerade die 12
13-jährigen dass die jetzt gerade so im
Fokus stehen finde ich ist auch gut
nachvollziehbar das verstehe ich aber es
erklärt für mich jetzt noch nicht warum
man dann alle zwölfjährige umbringt
warum man wie in Heide ein Mädchen über
Stunden hinweg erniedrigt Haare anzündet
und so weiter und filmt ja
klar ich mache jetzt mal ganz
grundsätzlich es hat ja eben auch gehört
ich bin nur wirklicher küchenpsychologe
dieser Begriff der der
Frustrationstoleranz dass man dass man
sozusagen weniger aushält weniger
resilient ist und zwar sozusagen weniger
psychisch widerstandsfähig schneller
zuschlägt schneller übergriffig wird wie
würden sie das erklären
naja also aggressives Verhalten ist
wirklich was was sich sehr früh zeigt
sehr chronisch ist und auch persistiert
ja das kann in dem Kita-Alter schon
auftreten Grundschulalter auftreten und
was ich eben regelhaft erlebe ist dass
wenig passiert es wird eher
bagatellisiert und nicht konsequent
psychiatrisch psychotherapeutisch
behandelt oder gegebenenfalls sogar
medikamentös wenn die Impulsivität auch
so stark ist und dann kann natürlich so
ein Teufelskreis sich entwickeln ne aber
es muss nicht immer eine psychische
Erkrankung dahinter stecken aber es ist
möglich dass es das ist das gibt wenn
sie sagen das zeigt sich schon sehr früh
kann sich ruhig sein ja genau also kann
sich frühzeitig woran würden sie das
dann festmachen ganz konkret was gucken
uns viele Leute zu die wollen verstehen
habe mich dann wirklicherweise auch ein
Thema an welcher Stelle müssen wir
aufnehmen ja das ist die Kita Erzieher
berichten dass das Kind schlägt und
beißt zum Beispiel hatte ich jetzt
neulich eine Vorstellung ich finde da
muss man genau hingucken woran liegt das
ist es ein geistig behindertes Kind hat
das Kind ein Autismus Problem oder ist
es eine aggressionsentwick den ich in
die richtigen Bahnen geht warum auch
immer weil im häuslichen Bereich auch
Gewalt ist oder es noch andere
Schwierigkeiten gibt also ich finde
einfach nur frühzeitig wie bei jeder
anderen Erkrankung auch er sollte da
eben interveniert werden das ist ja eben
im psychiatrischen Bereich immer noch so
dass viele Hemmungen haben dort aktiv zu
werden zum Kinder- und Jugendpsychiater
zu gehen so weiter bei uns ist es wie
bei jedem anderen Arzt auch hier früher
ich jemand kommt desto besser können wir
helfen weil psychische Erkrankung
brauchen auch lange Zeit bis sie sich
entwickeln bis man sie auch wieder
behandeln kann und wie gesagt wenn
aggressives Verhalten vor dem zehnten
Lebensjahr auftaucht ist das von der
Prognose her extrem ungünstig und ne
führt dann eben ich sage immer direkt
ins Gefängnis dann gibt es dreijährigen
90ern schon angefangen hat und die über
Jahrzehnte tatsächlich begleitet hat
festgestellt hat also kriminologische
Untersuchungen dass eben eine ganz
kleine Gruppe die solche Auffälligkeiten
hatte tatsächlich kriminelle Karriere
hingelegt haben also signifikant
also die die sind aus den 90ern haben
die begonnen diese Untersuchung von
denen rede ich also durchaus dass man
hier und da solche solche Dinge weiß ich
kann mich erinnern dass ich ihn quasi
Corona angesprochen haben
2020 glaube ich also war Corona und
nicht ganz so lange unter uns März 2020
ging es los genau ich aber im März war
das Gespräch noch nicht von dem ich
erzählen wollte Professor Karl Rutz das
ein Forscher im Bereich
Krisenintervention weniger Monate nach
dem Corona gestartet hat wie es er
darauf hin dass es
signifikante psychische Auffälligkeiten
unter Kindern und Jugendlichen gäbe
immer wieder immer wieder also insoweit
deckt sich das durchaus ich will jetzt
nicht sagen dass das direkte
Kausalitäten gibt aber zumindest der
Befund der der
Korrelation sagen wir mal möglicherweise
Frau Kümmel dieser Punkt den Frau Winter
gerade eben nur kurz angesprochen hat
sie beschäftigen sie viel mit Social
Media wir haben gerade eingangs über
über tiktok gesprochen eine chinesische
Plattform in dem Fall extrem populär und
der Kindern und Jugendlichen dieses
sozusagen
diese diese Vereinzelung die da
stattgefunden hat dieses wirklich einsam
werden und sich dann versenken in diese
digitale Welt sich zurückziehen zu Hause
im Kinderzimmer auf dem Sofa wo auch
immer kein physischer Kontakt mehr mit
Freunden draußen keine Begegnung mehr
was hat das mit Kindern und Jugendlichen
gemacht oder was macht das mit dem
ich glaube wir müssen uns hier einfach
noch mal anschauen Corona war eine
besondere Zeit aber generell
gibt es Entwicklungsaufgaben im Leben
und das ist ganz besonders bei
Kindern im pubertierenden Alter also das
ist dann so 12 bis 14 15 immer dieses
Alter sprechen weil hier geht es um die
Identitätsentwicklung hier geht es
tatsächlich darum zu entdecken wer bin
ich wohin will ich wie finden mich die
anderen und das ist das Besondere was
Social Media Kindern bietet die können
wirklich über das wie sie sich
darstellen ausprobieren
wir sprechen hier auch von emotionalen
Triebkräften des Menschen die unsere
Handeln
tatsächlich lenken das heißt wir haben
ganz hohes anerkennungsbedürfnis in der
Regel und dann kriegst du die
like-gruppe dazu gehören genau wir
wollen uns als kompetent erleben wirksam
erleben und Social Media bietet es
unseren Kindern und Jugendlichen das
heißt wenn ich mich heute jetzt mal
ausprobieren will toll Schminke und so
ein bisschen Pause dann habe ich hier
ein paar tolle likes und mir geht es gut
wenn sie Kinder und Jugendliche Fragen
aber hör mal du weißt doch es kann auch
anders kommen du kannst auch schlechte
Kommentare bekommen wie gehst du damit
um dann sagen viele ich glaube das
kriege ich schon hin so viel wird es
nicht sein die erhoffen sich wirklich
dass sie über die positiven Kommentare
sich einfach gut fühlen dass sie sich da
das ist ja alles nachvollziehbar ja aber
umgekehrt ist das natürlich auch dieser
Tage in der Studie gelesen
es ist erschreckend wie viele Kinder
berichten Opfer von Mobbing von
sexueller Gewalt zu werden zum Teil bis
zu 50%, das würde bedeuten jeder zweite
halten Sie das für realistisch an
Schulen also ich habe jetzt tatsächlich
noch mal recherchiert auch wir haben
Studien die sagen international ist es
eins von drei Kindern in Europa haben
wir eher die Zahlen dass wir sagen
zwischen 17 und 25 Prozent der Kinder
wurden im letzten Jahr mit Mobbing
konfrontiert persönlich also da haben
wir auch eine spannende und es ist auch
hier wieder das Thema dass wir vor allem
in diesem Altersbereich der Pubertät die
Spitzen haben also vor allem immer in
diesem Bereich wo es darum geht sich vom
Elternhaus abzukoppeln erwachsen werden
zu dürfen und sich selbst entdecken